okay so here we are the season finale of
eating your feed I'm Nikki and I'm
Andrew today we have a very special
episode it's brought to us by pure Leafs
new herbal iced teas our friend Adam has
challenged us to make a flower pot cake
okay so this cake is made at a place
called our dam you are done which is
garden in front it's literally a flower
pot I think it's a chocolate shell
mm-hmm it's just chocolate layered with
cake and mousse and jam like a regular
cake and then it's just decorated with
like flowers I know we always say this
but it doesn't look that difficult we
need to make a chocolate mold cake a
mousse jam and the crumb topping that
looks like dirt okay so we have a very
special episode mm-hmm you also have a
very special guest world-renowned chef
Marcus Samuelsson we're trying to make
this cake that looks like a flowerpot
yeah that's beautiful so we're trying to
figure out a game plan on how we're
gonna make this thing you want to melt
the chocolate right stuck there she put
a big brainian water boil and then you
put the chocolate in very often you put
the butter right next to it to cake it
needs to be moist right so that means
that you create a simple syrup infuse
that into the cake you'll help us if we
got stuck right here okay
okay we're making the chocolate pot I
have a variety of pots here's some
actual terra cotta ones we also have
like a popcorn bucket yeah this is the
material I'm most confident in but this
might be too big I want to look
impressive so I think we should try with
that so we have to temper chocolate I
don't entirely know what that means have
you done that before I haven't done it
but I've seen it done and it looks
really hard
Oh temper temperature is that it I just
want to call out this is some beautiful
manners croplife okay Marcus said double
boiler so we need water and this guy the
temperature of the chocolate can't
exceed 120 degrees Fahrenheit so if we
do that with all this chocolate it's
game over
chopping chocolate is my new favorite
thing
oh yeah okay so take out half a pound
okay so Marcus also suggested adding
some butter to the chocolate when we
melt it because texture high-five
nope it needs to get to a hundred and
twenty degrees this is fancy
that is a look she's melting but
chocolates melting fast oh it's at 106
let's take it off and then just stir it
for a bit Oh God 121 the metal bowls hot
it's still hot the chocolate itself is
covering it like 118 so see those
streaks yeah that might be bad we're
going to add the remaining third that's
all the chocolate so now we just keep
stirring until it gets down to about 82
so the chocolate has sufficiently cooled
now gently reheat it back to around 89
degrees this is the part where stirring
it regularly will really matter so now
we'll do a temper test we're going to
spread a little bit of chocolate onto
this wax paper here it should Harden and
become shiny and hard very quickly
yeah now that's completely liquid ah
gonna pop this in the fridge what do I
do with this alright maintain
temperature
it's it's good it is yeah I put it in
for three minutes
look at that that chocolate is in temper
so we'll pour it in and then kind of
yeah oh yeah hmm satisfied I look at I'm
really 50/50 on this wait wait put it in
the second bucket to stabilize the shape
because you're you're getting a little
galley one with this here yeah crazy
yeah let's go serious so it looks like a
pot full of chocolate it yes the
question is will it remove itself from
the popcorn tub oh I'm gonna get a pair
scissors ready snippet the tip oh okay
oh yes oh I just broke it do you want to
see what has happened I don't know how
to salvage this this was failure we're
gonna temper the chocolate again so I
think we definitely come in way under
120 yeah so we're gonna use a different
vessel to make the bucket shape this
time well we're gonna try a couple
different things one of them is going to
be a plastic cup that will put a glass
jar it we will still use our popcorn
bucket and maybe we should line it how's
it going pretty good I'm kind of going
on and off the heat
95 climbing okay I say we do a little
ice bath
well toe dip yeah we're close hot cold
hot cold hot cold hot cold so this
chocolate has reached temper so here's a
test beer beef
that was sixty seconds in the fridge
whoa
pretty now all right we're ready to dump
it in some buckets
dududududududududududu I don't think we
need to fill all the way no I'm gonna do
like halfway up and then it's really
good Oh into the freezer okay we should
just dump this all of it in right just
simple like okay parchment the parchment
is falling down because of chocolate
we're gonna this is the bed we've made
now we have to sleep in that freezer
okay so we are using a tasty chocolate
cake recipe it's flour cocoa powder salt
baking soda and baking powder
stout yes which is beer
don't Oh yep determine that it was gonna
be vanilla
espresso powder butter sugar eggs
mayonnaise what kind of cake is this is
this a lie so to give you an idea of how
much cake we're making Moo we're gonna
sift together dry ingredients so now we
have to combine the stout with the
espresso powder and the vanilla okay
this is weird why wouldn't let's go in
the dry ingredients needs to dissolve
otherwise you're just eating them got it
lower okay can you cream the butter hey
Ken 5 minutes till she's fluffy 6 eggs 1
hand
whoa professor there's that mayonnaise
smell is this bowl big enough
okay found a really big bowl
approximately 1/3 comes here's some beer
oh we have to fold in chocolate chunks
ready yeah
the bowl is enormous and you're missing
yeah Oh decent right oh it's great I
don't bake it's time to put this in the
oven 35 minutes hey what's up guys oh
hey you got there I was thinking maybe I
should do a cocktail for you guys okay
Oh maracas bay rum punch one punch yeah
just like making a chocolate cake like a
cocktail is all about textures and
flavors so this is peach biscuit sea ice
cube ice cubes just gonna add the entity
it's caffeine free which is always good
to have something that's caffeine free
sure let's really take great care prod
in the ingredient that the source super
fruit-forward lime juice simple syrup
dark rum and also some honey bourbon
you're gonna shake that okay I see you
so I'm just gonna take a little bit of
this rosemary and torch it just to open
up some of these flavors that we're
building floral flavor component squeeze
in a little more line you want to do the
honors nice and cold
look at that right and then I'm gonna
top it off with a little bit of soda
just to get some bubbles lovely it's
cream cheese Cheers
yeah every challenge should be Adam do
you want to take what you want try one
nice right oh yeah okay thanks for the
drinks we're gonna get back to the cake
all right thank you
so the Moose is essentially whipping a
bunch of cream and making a ganache and
then just combining them higher half a
cup of heavy cream we're gonna heat it
and then pour it over your chocolate oh
this is getting hot girl fast two cups
of cream sugar in here and we're now
just gonna pour the hot cream over the
chocolate and then count to thirty
thirteen fourteen seventeen twenty nine
other than thirty seconds exactly
Wow Wow you're doing it well I'm gonna
stir it to help cool it down nothing
yeah why does it look chunky what did
you do did you over stir no it looked
really good earlier it does not look so
good now looks grainy oh okay
so I think this chocolate is seized and
a drop of water could help so I have a
little bit of water here oh that looks
better
can I fold yeah I want you to fold Wow
is it good yeah
the cake is coming together I think
we're gonna take up Marcos on his offer
to make the simple syrup keep the cake
moist since we have them today just
bring them on see how it's done how's it
going how's it going it's going yeah
cool all right when we have this great
peach hibiscus tea why not use it right
yeah so oh so we have sugar we also want
to make it like not too sugary that's
what we're just having plain all good on
water all we do is we're gonna bring
this to you boy right you want all the
sugar to dissolve and then we'll just
put that on top of the cake
yeah you want to sort of brush it on
right paint it on okay so you guys later
see you later syrup it's time to make
the cake
okay look at that cake assembly oh and
we're filling this before we unmold it
right yeah as it is alone it's very
fragile and I don't want it to crack
like when it did last time yeah I don't
think if it's filled it's a little
sturdier and it will be less likely to
crack you punch enough cake while you is
on the race ice yeah
are you sure you want a little mousse at
the bottom a little mousse at the bottom
first layer of cake oh that's okay
that's a pave let's do a little bit of
ice cool cool cool cool cool
oh nice syrup that oh this is very jelly
jelly I will say the bucket feels very
firm this time around I'm gonna cut out
in a third piece I don't know a guy
parallel park these layers into the
we're just gonna cut this see if it'll
unmold nicely okay though the chocolate
has a nice snap to it okay okay okay
the force of actually tearing is what
scares oh my god are you nervous I'm
very nervous
be gentle be gentle bees even told you
their heroic music I can't believe that
worked
it's coming yeah generous oh yeah
okay so I'm thinking we should just put
these crumbs into the oven for a bit
yeah should we chip away some of the
Trump I don't know how to do that
carefully okay so based on Adams idea we
have a baking sheet exactly like this
one
preheating the oven I'm gonna take it
out and smush it on top create a
perfectly flat layer it's not that hot
oh that's very satisfying whoa
pretty good idea Adam I cannot believe
that word
okay so now we need to make this look
like a flower pot and what they do in
the video is they airbrush the airbrush
it with an edible paint the gist is got
this gun we're gonna put some color in
here and then you spray I'm gonna start
with canary yellow okay I might join you
with some sunset orange okay we got this
thing great there it goes oh okay that's
just interesting not something I was
prepared for it to be honest chocolate
is not taking to the color
yeah there's looks viscous look at this
it's metallic but it's not translucent
little puffs some in here yeah why not
all right here we go
[Music]
yes maybe you know that's just it's
gonna be a little bit of artistic
interpretation of the flower pot here i
won yeah okay Oh what do you do that mom
just all comes off we in fact we could
just wipe off all of it and today never
happened it looks kind of nice has like
a nice you know it looks more expensive
feel like we have to hide the evidence
of our filled painting like that
painting we never tried anything I'm
pretty pleased with this I'm very
pleased we weren't even sure if we'd
have a pot no okay
let's top it with some of this dirt
crumb this looks like dirt
they fly this onto the cake stand art
[Music]
the less you think about it the better
it'll I'm worried about this sliding
yeah this is your rotating by yeah we
don't need that the cake is just about
finished time to write Marcus back I'm
hiding this because Marcus is back and I
want him to be really wowed wait what
are you expecting
I expect the delicious beautiful cake he
doesn't know us at all okay ready yeah
Wow we got the dirt and we got the crust
outside and we got some of viscous here
yeah oh okay we do that okay take there
tight oh that's nice
should we go with the Malkin table right
away nice oh my god beautiful this is
wild just did an awesome job it's just
pretty well uh let's do it the big cut
I'm really worried we'll just completely
fall apart here I go
ooh okay they had a nice crack to it
yeah here comes scape this is the
important part huh how it is oh right oh
yeah really good yeah it's hibiscus it's
not for all the dried ones are great
with the chocolate yeah real nice and
crunchy and fruit-forward I actually
also love the dirt and give you that
nice ransacked look I cannot believe we
did this did a good job are you gonna do
oh okay this have been season two of
eating your feed we made a flower pot
game and thank you Marcus for joining us
today
great job guess clearly graduate thank
you
oh yes